the jurogan experience have you ever
considered something
alternative to uh air inflated tires
have you seen some of these
these alternatives that have essentially
spaces
in between the upper wall and the wheel
have you thought about that
yeah we've had uh we haven't found a
you know uh a tire that
because you gotta worry about road noise
uh you gotta
take out uh potholes and bumps
um you got to have like a
good grip but you also want to have low
rolling resistance so that you know you
get good range
those are a lot of things to try to put
into one
tire um then if you also say and it
can't have air
it's like this is hard so you're talking
i'm talking to a guy who's putting
people on mars
you can't figure out an airless tire
it's just
it's it's an incremental constraint um
i'm not saying there won't be such a
thing i think there will be too precise
because it seems like we've just gotten
way too comfortable with this idea that
tires blow out
and you get flats it's very annoying
that's annoying yeah
very annoying yeah um
in non-sport tires by the way i'm much
less likely to go to have flats because
they're sure
they're more bounce yeah like you let's
say you hit you hit the edge of a
pothole
if you got more rubber wall you know you
got a longer way to go before
you pinch the tire so um
sport tires tend to that have more flats
especially in l.a potholes that's the
worst yeah like
there was one particular pothole on
sunset boulevard
they would just take out so many model s
like boom boom both sides of the car
really yeah damn
um yeah steven spielberg was actually
once
it's like hey steven's people focus like
two times when i was like god damn it i
know that pothole
um i feel like you can pay to fix that i
mean
fix that pothole it seems like that's
actually it'll be like
man there sure a lot of taxes in
california for roads this bad yeah
the place is a mess yeah um so so
ultimately one day that's a possibility
of having some sort of an airless tire
because i've seen prototypes
i've never seen one on an actual car in
physical in in real life yeah i think
we're
the technology is gradually getting
there um
and i think for something like a robo
taxi where you want to have the tires
last for a long time and not go flat
um it's going to make a lot of sense
yeah
um but other than that essentially
most of what we saw in the demo is the
same it's still going to have
now oh yeah there was the issue with the
glass when
yeah that accidentally shot that how
annoying was that
that was shocking i mean
we literally spent you know hours
beforehand with like
lots of people throwing uh steel balls
at the window right um i mean we must
have thrown
at least at least a dozen people must
have thrown
steel balls at the same window though
yes isn't that the problem
yeah that might it turns out that might
be a problem
if you keep throwing steel balls
eventually it's gonna break
and and i did i did ask france to really
wind up and give it all
you know and i should she was sort of
like oh take it easy yeah you know give
me
you don't need to wind up yeah we don't
need the fastball
but i asked for i did ask for the
fastball and like okay let's go for the
slightly not slightly slower ball do you
think it was because you guys were
hitting the sidewall with a sledgehammer
yeah
that could be like trying to figure out
how the hell this thing break because
i mean we were just bouncing steel balls
off it all day right um
and we think possibly what what might
have happened there
was that uh hitting it with a
sledgehammer might have cracked the base
of it
and once you crack the base of it it
loses all the strength right um and then
it and then it would just have a
hairline fracture and then then you hit
you hit it anywhere it's going to
shatter did you recreate that
we didn't um it's also hard with
uh test glass like with uh you know that
like when you actually do production
glass
it's much more robust than uh demo glass
uh because production glass you you you
know
um like demo glasses you just can't make
you you have to have like
massive tools and ovens and everything
to to make the production glass it's
it's like
and if you don't you know that takes a
while to do
so the production class is always better
than than
than demo glass um nonetheless it should
have worked
um and it was probably because we
whacked it with a sledgehammer and then
threw the steel ball at it
but but uh it will be bulletproof to a
handgun now why did you decide to do all
that
make it bulletproof and make it like you
could hit it with a sledgehammer like
what
what was the motivation to make it
different than just like a model s
i mean i think you know it's like what's
cool about a truck trucks are tough
and like okay what's tougher than a
truck a tank what about a tank from the
future
[Laughter]
okay now you have a tank from the future
okay
yeah that's bulletproof yeah and
how's that compared to you know it was
way tougher than a regular truck look
it's [ __ ] cool yeah there's no doubt
i don't have some character from the
future that [ __ ] like halo with a rocket
launcher in the back
have you thought about doing something
like that somebody's gonna do it for
sure for military use
yeah seems like it i mean i don't know
that sounds like it'd be fun i mean
like you know cruising around the field
and like
lobbying shooting rockets now is there
ever a possibility that these things
going to be solar powered
is that is that someday is the solar
technology going to get to a point where
it's kind of a surface area issue so i
mean i think you could possibly put the
the cover of the truck bed um you know
put some solar cells in that so if you
just leave it out in the sun
you know probably bring you know
recharges a few miles a day type of
thing
it was only it would only be a few
months but what about one day
is it possible the technology could
evolve to the point where they could
extract
no really no it's a so there's about
one kilowatt per square meter of solar
energy and then
you're going to get uh probably 20 25
efficiency so you got 200 watts a square
meter and then that's assuming that
you're normal to the sun
so you know like you're you know at the
right angles basically like
are you facing the sun or not so
you know we add all those things up you
say how many square meters can you
really get
and then how many what hours per mile
so it is basically
if you could do 10 miles a day you'd be
lucky really
yeah and that's not gonna change no
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience